E
HOUSE MAYORKAS WILL BE HELD TO
ACCOUNT.
HERE TO HELP US MAKE SOME SENSE
OF WHAT IS NOT MAKING SENSE AT
ALL IS LOUISIANA SENATOR BILL
CASSIDY.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU HERE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
CRITICIZED TITLE 42, NOW THEY
ARE USING IT BUT ONLY FOR
VENEZUELANS, THEY HAVE A 24,000
THEY ARE ALLOWING AND ILLEGALLY
BUT THEY KNOW IT WILL NOT BE
ENOUGH.
THE BLACK MARKET FOR THAT, CAN
YOU HELP US MAKE SENSE OF THIS?
>> THE BIDEN MINISTRATION WANTS
OPEN BORDERS, EFFECTIVELY THEY
WANT THAT AND THIS IS TOTALLY
OUT OF CONTROL, EVEN THEY HAVE
TO DO SOMETHING SO THEY ARE
GOING BACK TO POLICIES THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION DID, THE LAST
POLICIES THAT WORK, CAMPAIGN
AGAINST THEM, YOU GOT TO BE
QUIET ABOUT THIS, TURNS OUT
THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT WORK
AND BY THE WAY IF YOU THINK
VENEZUELA IS AN ISSUE WAIT AND
SEE WHAT IS ABOUT TO HAPPEN IN
HAITI.
HAITI WHERE THERE'S GANGS, WE
ARE GOING TO STOP SHIPPING RICE
TO HAITI BECAUSE THE GANGS HAVE
TAKEN OVER LEANING MASS
STARVATION WHICH MEANS HAITIANS
WILL BECOMING MORE THAN THAT IS
WHELAN'S.
I AM NOT QUITE SURE WHY THEY
DID IT.
IT DEAL TO STRONG-ARM THE
VENEZUELAN GOVERNMENT TO GIVE
US OIL.
WE WILL ASK THE VENEZUELANS TO
PRODUCE THERE IS.
I WOULD RATHER JOBS IN
LOUISIANA THAN VENEZUELA BUT
THAT IS THIS ADMINISTRATION.
RACHEL: YOU MENTIONED HAITIANS.
PETE: MAYORKAS NEW THAT THE
WHIPPING STORY WASN'T TRUE WHEN
HE WENT IN FRONT OF THE MEDIA
AND DISPARAGED THOSE AGENTS.
ACCOUNTABLE TO COMING AT ANY
POINT?
>> IT STARTS AT THE TOP, HE'S A
MAN TAKING ORDERS, YOU'RE GOING
TO GO SAY THIS AND MAY HAVE
SAID IT AND WE DON'T CARE, YOU
ARE GOING TO SAY IT.
IF YOU WANT ACCOUNTABILITY VOTE
REPUBLICAN IN THE MIDTERMS.
JOE: LOOKING AT THE MIDTERMS,
EVERYONE BELIEVES THE HOUSE
WILL FLIP TO REPUBLICAN CONTROL
IN THE SENATE, A LOT OF EXPERTS
SAY ONE OR 2 SENATORS CAN GO
EITHER WAY.
IF WE END UP IN A SITUATION
WHERE THE HOUSE AND SENATE ARE
REPUBLICAN-CONTROLLED, BIDEN
STILL IN THE WHITE HOUSE, BACK
TO THIS WATER ISSUE, PROBABLY
NOT GOING TO LET YOU FUND THE
WALL, WHAT CAN YOU DO TO SECURE
THE BORDER?
>> CONGRESS, FORTUNATELY
CONGRESS IS GIVEN THE EXECUTIVE
EVERYTHING THEY NEED TO SECURE
THE BORDER AS WELL AS IT CAN BE
SECURED, THE EXECUTIVE DOESN'T
WANT TO USE IT.
IT IS LIKE PUSHING WET TOILET
PAPER, TRYING TO GET A LITTLE
BIT OF PUSHBACK, YOU CAN'T.
THE ADMINISTRATION WILL NOT --
WON'T ENFORCED THE LAW, WON'T
-- TRYING TO REPEAL TITLE 42.
BEST WE CAN DO, WON'T SAY THE
BEST, WE WILL DO OUR BEST TO
GET THEM TO ENFORCE THE LAWS
THAT ARE THERE BUT IF THEY WANT
TO ROPE A DOPE, PRETEND THEY
CAN'T DO WHAT THEY HAVE A LOT
OF TOOLS TO DO IT.
PETE: PRESIDENT BIDEN ON THE
WEST COAST CLAIMING IF
REPUBLICANS TAKE CHARGE THEY
WILL MAKE INFLATION WORSE.
PLEASE TRANSLATE AND EXPLAIN
HIS ATTEMPT.
>> SOMETIMES YOU GOT TO LAUGH.
THEY PASSED THE ONE.
9 TRILLION AMERICAN, CALLED IT
RECOVERY ACT, PROGRAM,
WHATEVER, AMERICAN RECESSION,
WHAT THEY DID.
WHAT IS LEFT IS IT WOULD DRIVE
UP INFLATION AND IT DID.
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO PUT A
STOP ON UNNECESSARY SPENDING,
DO OUR BEST TO OPEN UP NORTH
AMERICAN ENERGY PRODUCTION.
RACHEL: CAN YOU DO IT?
>> YOU CAN DO IT BY SAYING
OKAY, AGENCY AND UNTIL YOU
START ISSUING PERMITS WE WILL
PUT A SQUEEZE ON YOU, THE POWER
OF THE PURSE.
RACHEL: LET'S HOPE REPUBLICANS
USE THAT POWER.
THAT IS ARE YOU GOT.
>> Reporter: ALWAYS TENSION
BETWEEN AN EXECUTIVE THE
DOESN'T WANT TO DO SOMETHING
OUT OF CONGRESS WHICH IS TRYING
TO GET THEM.
YOU USE WHATEVER TOOL YOU CAN
BECAUSE WHAT IS AT STAKE, HOW
DO WE GET THAT BUDGET IN BETTER
SHAPE?
JOE: TALKING ABOUT INFLATION, A
LOT OF YOUR COLLEAGUES WOULD
SAY MUCH OF OUR ECONOMIC WOES
COME FROM OUR ENERGY POLICY.
PRESIDENT BIDEN MADE SOME NEWS,
SAUDI ARABIA DID SAYING THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION REQUESTED
OIL PRODUCTION BE CUT AFTER THE
MIDTERMS, POLITICAL MOVE THERE
BUT WHAT DOES THAT SAY FOR
LOOKING OUT FOR AMERICANS?
>> IF YOU ARE AT HOME PAYING
THAT MUCH MORE FOR YOUR
UTILITIES AND THAT MUCH MORE
FOR YOUR GASOLINE AND THAT MUCH
MORE FOR YOUR HEATING OIL YOU
ARE THINKING WHAT IS HAPPENING?
JOE: YOUR MAJOR FORMS OF
ENERGY, WE READ THEM OFF.
>> THIS ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT
COMPARE ABOUT FAMILY STRUGGLING
AROUND THE KITCHEN TABLE AND
THEY WILL TELL YOU OTHERWISE
BUT IN PRACTICE IT IS TRUE.
PETE: WE KNOW THIS IS ABOUT THE
ELECTION, THAT IS HOW WE REACT
TO THIS REALITY THAT SAUDI
ARABIA SAID NO TO BIDEN'S
ATTEMPT TO MEDDLE IN THE
ELECTION.
THE OTHER SIDE SPENT FOUR YEARS
TRYING TO IMPEACH DONALD TRUMP
USING A PHONE CALL TO SAY HE
MEDDLED IN AN ELECTION NONE OF
WHICH WAS TRUE.
WHY DID THEY -- I'M NOT GOING
TO ASK.
WHY DID THEY GET AWAY WITH IT?
RACHEL: A GREAT QUESTION, ALSO
THREATENED WE ARE NOT GOING TO
GIVE YOU WEAPONS, ISN'T THAT
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE UKRAINE,
ACCUSED TRUMP OF USING SALE OF
WEAPONS TO UKRAINE AS THE SAME
THING, A BARGAINING CHIP?
WE CANNOT HAVE A COUNTRY WITH
NOT SAME THE SAME RULES.
>> I AM FROM A STATE IN WHICH
HUNDRED OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
HAVE A BETTER LIVING BECAUSE WE
HAVE NORTH AMERICAN ENERGY
PRODUCTION.
MY STATE, OUR COUNTRY, OUR
FAMILIES ARE STRONGER WHEN WE
DEVELOP OUR OWN RESOURCES, THE
PRESIDENT IS BEGGING OTHER
COUNTRIES TO INCREASE THEIR
RESOURCES.
THEY ARE GOING TO DO WHAT IS IN
THEIR BEST INTERESTS.
I ASKED, MISTER PRESIDENT, DO
WHAT IS IN THE INTERESTS OF THE
AMERICAN FAMILY, DEVELOP OUR
OWN RESOURCES, DRIVE DOWN THE
COST OF ALL THESE FUELS, DRIVE
UP THE WAGES OF FELLOW
AMERICANS.
MR.
PRESIDENT, PLEASE DO THAT, THEN
YOU WILL BE DOING YOUR JOB.
>> WITH YOU IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT THE WAY THEY
IMPEACHED DONALD TRUMP FOR THE
SAME THING?
>> IMPEACHMENT STARTS IN THE
HOUSE.
THEY WILL DECIDE IF THERE IS
GOING TO BE AN IMPEACHMENT.
PETE: SHOULD THEY DO THAT?
>> LET'S LOOK AT THE CHARGES,
YOU DON'T WANT TO MAKE
IMPEACHMENT A POLITICAL --
RACHEL: BUT THEY DO.
PETE: A LOT OF THINGS
REPUBLICANS --
>> THIS IS ABOUT OUR COUNTRY IN
THE FUTURE, TIT FOR TAT, THERE
IS SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
IMPEACHABLE HE SHOULD BE
IMPEACHED, IF THERE IS
SOMETHING THAT IT IS PAYBACK
TIME I'M UNCOMFORTABLE.
RACHEL: IS HE IMPEACHABLE IF HE
DID IT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
RACHEL: WITHHOLDING OIL TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE SAUDI'S
TO DO THAT?
>> I DON'T KNOW THAT.
DON'T KNOW IF THAT BREAKS THE
CONSTITUTION.
THAT IS WHAT IT IS.
RACHEL: THEY MADE SO MANY
CHARGES AGAINST TRUMP THAT WERE
TRUMPED UP OR CREATED THAT IT
CAUSES US TO SAY IF THAT IS
YOUR STANDARD WHY CAN'T THIS BE
THE STANDARD, THAT'S THE
FRUSTRATING PART, THERE ARE TWO
STANDARDS, THE CHALLENGE FOR
THE INCOMING CONGRESS IF YOU
GET THE GAVEL, PRESENTING AN
ALTERNATIVE AND A LOT OF PEOPLE
CLAMORING FOR ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> IF YOU IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT, WHO WILL TAKE HIS
PLACE?
RACHEL: THERE IS ALWAYS THAT.
JOE: MAY BE SMARTER ABOUT THIS
THAN WE THOUGHT.
PETE: YOU ARE BIG LSU TIGERS
FAN.
WE ARE A LITTLE BIT OF A
REBUILDING YEAR, NEED TO SPREAD
AROUND A LITTLE BIT LIKE
GEORGIA.
PETE: IN TENNESSEE TALKING
ABOUT BEING A FAN OF THAT, HE
MARRIED INTO LSU RATHER THAN
BEING IN THE GOOD HANDS THEM GO
WITH THE NEXT TIGER.
PETE: JUSTIN JEFFERSON 18 -- IN
YOUR CLOSET.
JOE: YOU ARE A SOCIAL CLIMBER.